this is a second thought video made
possible by tab for a cause
install the free browser extension and
start making a difference today
if this is your first time visiting the
channel make sure to subscribe and click
the little bell to join the notification
squad
okay show of hands how many of you drink
at least one can of soda per day
probably quite a few especially for
those of us in the west
despite what sugary drink manufacturers
would have you believe you're not going
to change the world or become a super
trendy influencer by drinking their
product
in fact it might cause just the opposite
these days
soda is a staple at parties sporting
events lunch and dinner outings and
basically anywhere else beverages are
served
the average american drinks almost 45
gallons of soft drinks every year
compared to around 58 gallons of water
that's a huge amount
but our soda consumption is actually
down from its peak in 1998
when we drank 58 gallons each year this
decline has largely been caused by
concerns of growing obesity rates in the
united states
soda has been a major culprit in the
drastically increased rates of
overweight and obesity
and that's not the only health problem
linked to our sugary friend
the negative side effects of drinking
soda extend to just about every organ in
the body
so what would happen if you cut soda out
of your diet
the second you decide to put down your
favorite soft drink you're putting your
body back on the right track
high blood pressure will begin to lower
back down to normal levels
and you'll be 20 percent less likely to
develop chronic heart disease as someone
who drinks soda every day
your brain will thank you too a lot of
people rely on the caffeine in sugary
drinks to make it through the afternoon
at work or school
and while a soda may give you the little
boost you need to make it to the end of
the day
the long-term effect on your brain can
be pretty severe
one study found that long-term
consumption of sugary beverages could
cause impaired learning
memory and behavioral plasticity other
studies have often found a link between
sugary drinks and an increased risk of
alzheimer's and other forms of dementia
cutting soda out of your diet will
drastically improve your overall brain
function and protect you from serious
memory conditions in the long term
in the short term you'll begin to feel
more awake and alert during the day once
you've broken your dependency on the
sugar and caffeine kick soda provides
your bones will also benefit from
quitting soda significantly lowering
your chances of developing osteoporosis
and other bone disorders
the acids and soda contribute to a
gradual weakening of your bones to the
point where breaks and fractures are
much more common
the less soda you drink the stronger
your bones will become
your kidney health will begin to improve
drastically studies have indicated that
drinking large amounts of soda can lead
to kidney disease and ultimately
complete kidney failure
to make things worse in some cases soft
drinks have been shown to contain bpa
which has been linked to an increase in
risk of breast and prostate cancer
premature puberty
infertility metabolic disorders and
diabetes
then of course there's obesity despite
all the serious health conditions soda
can cause
obesity gets the spotlight probably
because it's the most obvious side
effect
as everything else is happening behind
the scenes simply replacing soda with
water can make a huge difference in your
weight
drinking water first thing in the
morning kickstarts your metabolism
a study on obese children found that
drinking a glass of cold water raised
their resting energy expenditure by 25
percent
people who drink at least one to one and
a half liters of water per day for a few
weeks typically see a noticeable
reduction in weight
bmi and waist circumference your skin
will be clearer and smoother within
weeks
and adequate water intake helps to
prevent aging and all of this is just
the benefits of drinking water in
general
if you were to completely replace soda
with water the change in your overall
health would be dramatic
and you'd add years to your life in the
long term so if you want to avoid
diseases of every organ in the body
obesity and brittle bones maybe cut back
on the soda a bit
and try water instead here's a bit of
perspective to make transitioning to
water a little bit easier
just think of how fortunate we are to
even have such an abundance of clean
drinking water
when there are so many places around the
world where clean water is hard to come
by
if you want to help take two seconds to
install the new and improved tab for a
cause extension for your web browser
tab for a cause is a browser extension
that donates to a charity of your choice
each time you open a new tab without
costing you a thing
just by browsing the web tabbers have
now raised more than 450
thousand dollars for charity through tab
for a cause installing the extension
takes almost no effort and lets you make
a real difference every single day
just by using your web browser click the
link in the description to start tabbing
for your cause today
if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support the channel and
click the little bell to join the
notification squad
you can watch my previous video by
clicking here or if you're really bored
you can binge watch all my content by
clicking here
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week